so scarlett johansson is suing disney  which is unfortunate but her contract  clearly states that most of the money  that she was gonna make on the movie is  coming from the theater box office so  the fact that disney released it on  disney plus premier access  and in theaters at the same time was a  breach of her contract it was supposed  to come out in theaters first  so now she's suing disney and  rightfully so i guess since it is a  violation of the contract but this is  most likely going to be  the end of premiere access unless they  seriously renegotiate the deals with the  actors which  they're not going to want once theaters  get back to normal in like  maybe a year or so where it's like  literally everybody's going back to the  theaters nobody's going to want that so  this might be the end of premiere access  thanks to scarlett johansson suing  disney